[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> HEY HEY.
ALRIGHT.
GOOD TO BE HERE.
FLEW IN FROM NEW YORK.
STAYING RIGHT IN THE HEART OF
WEST HOLLYWOOD.
GREAT NEIGHBORHOOD.
THE GAY PRIDE GOES RIGHT BY MY
HOUSE EVERY DAY.
I LIKE A GAY AREA.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS NICE ABOUT
BEING GAY, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WONDER EVERY OTHER DAY IF YOU'RE
GAY.
[LAUGHING]
>> I LIKE DUDES, I'M GOING TO
WORK.
YOU CAN JUST ENJOY A POOL PARTY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE CONFUSED.
I LOOK AT GAY MEN LIKE
MARIJUANA.
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER IT WAS NOT
FOR ME.
NOW IT'S ACCEPTABLE.
YA I'LL DABBLE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> YA.
I DON'T KNOW I'M A WEIRD GUY.
OUTSIDE OF THIS I DON'T LIKE
ATTENTION.
I NEVER ORDER FAJITAS.
TOO MUCH, YOU KNOW.
JUST TRYING TO MIND YOUR OWN
BUSINESS.
SOME GUY COMES IN.
CAN'T YOU JUST FINISH COOKING
THAT BEFORE YOU LEAVE THE
KITCHEN.
MAN, ORDERING FAJITAS ALIKE A
FRIEND THAT VAPE TAOZ MUCH.
I'M GLAD YOU'RE HERE, BUT IT'S
EMBARRASSING.
YA, THEY SHOULD HAVE A WAY FOR
GUYS LIKE IN TO ORDER THEM.
I WILL TAKE THE CHICKEN FAJITAS
INTROVERT STYLE.
YOU GUYS I'M A LITTLE HUNGOVER I
WON'T LIE TO YOU.
I HAVE TO CUT BACK ON THE
DRINKING.
SAD I HAVE LOST FRIENDS TO
SOBRIETY.
YA, ALCOHOL IS THE ONLY VICE
WHEN SOMEONE QUITS YOU GET
ANNOYED.
YOU KNOW, YOUR FRIEND IS LIKE I
WILL QUIT DOING CRACK.
YOU'RE NEVER LIKE, WHAT ABOUT
THE WEDDING?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I FEEL LIKE IF I'M ADDICTED TO
ANY DRUG MY DRUG OF CHOICE IS
BEING LATE.
I KNOW YOU CAN'T SMOKE IT OR
SNORT IT.
IT'S LIKE A DRUG.
YOU HAVE TO BE AT WORK AT 9:00.
YOU HAVE TO BE AT WORK AT
9:30 YOU'RE UP.
HOLY HELL YOU LOOK LIKE A DRUG
ADDICT.
YOU GET TO WORK IT'S LIKE YOU'RE
COKED UP.
I'M SO SORRY.
I HATE MYSELF.
I'M GAY.
I LOVE YOU.
SO, SAD.
YA, I HAVE LOST JOBS,
RELATIONSHIPS, FRIENDS HATE ME
NOW.
I DON'T KNOW EVERY TIME I'M LATE
IT'S LIKE A DRUG.
I WILL NEVER DO THAT AGAIN.
I FEEL LIKE HELL.
I'M A HORRIBLE PERSON.
A WEEK LATER, I'M LATE ALL OVER.
I'VE OFF THE WAGON.
IT'S FREE AND LEGAL NO, CURE OF
IT EVEN IF FRIENDS AND FAMILY
GET TOGETHER.
MARK IS ALWAYS LATE.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A INTERVENTION.
BY THE TIME I SHOW UP THEY'RE
GONE.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS A SNEAKY DRUG,
CAFFEINE.
WE'RE ALL ADDICTED.
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO BE AN ADDICT.
YOU WAKE UP THE FIRST THING YOU
WANT.
YOU TURN ON THE COFFEE MAKER.
YOU MAKE THE DRUGS AT HOME.
THERE IS AN APPLIANCE FOR IT
THERE IS NO MR. METH.
YOU LOCK LIKE A ADDICT.
OPEN A DRAWER, PULL OUT THE BAG,
COLUMBIAN, RIGHT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> OH, YA.
THEN YOU GET TO WORK EVERYONE IS
CRACKED OUT.
I CAN'T FUNCTION WITHOUT COFFEE.
NO COFFEE NO WORKY.
YA, I WORKED AT A OFFICE A MEAN
LADY CAME IN EVERY DAY.
I'M NOT TALKING TO ANYONE UNTIL
I GET A CUP OF COFFEE.
I WAS LIKE GREAT, HIDE THE
COFFEE.
YA.
I WAS AT A COFFEE SHOP EARLIER .
SO BEAUTIFUL WOMEN IN THIS CITY
IT HAS TO BE HARD TO BE A LADY.
YOU'RE CONSTANTLY JUDGED BY YOUR
LOOKS.
I HAVE A FRIEND WHO A A COCKTAIL
WAITRESS.
SHE WAS FIRED FOR GAINING
WEIGHT.
ALTHOUGH I SEE POLICE OFFICERS
OVERWEIGHT EVERY DAY.
SHOULDN'T THEY -- SHE IS
BRINGING CHICKEN WINGS TO A
TABLE.
SHE MAY EAT ONE.
THESE ARE POLICE.
I WENT TO EUROPE THEY DON'T HAVE
GUNS.
THEY ARE CHASE AND TACKLE.
IN AMERICA, WE ARE LAZY.
I'M NOT RUNNING, BANG.
A CAR, BICYCLE.
NO MORE GUN, SWORD.
YOU HAVE TO GET IN THERE.
YA.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> YA.
>> YA, IT'S GOT TO BE
INTIMIDATING TO BE A LADY.
MY EX-GIRLFRIEND WAS PARANOID.
SAID I WAS CHEATING ON HER.
GO THROUGH THE CELLPHONE, SOCK
DRAWER, SNIFF ME, LOOKING FOR
CLUES.
I'M SURPRISED YOU DON'T SEW MORE
FEMALE DETECTIVES.
WOMEN WOULD BE AMAZING.
INTUITIVE AND PERSISTENT.
I FEEL YOU WOULD CRACK EVERY
CASE IF YOU FELT IT WAS
PERSONAL.
THAT'S THE KEY.
MAN THIS GUY KILLS PEOPLE IN
FRESNO.
HE'S ALSO SHEET KHA *ETING ON HI
WIFE.
GIVE ME THE FILE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THANKS A LOT I'M KEVIN HART.
HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> James: GREMARK NORMAN.
SEE HIM SEPTEMBER 28 AND 29 AT
GOTHAM COMEDY CLUB IN NEW YORK
CITY.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BAck
THAT WAS REALLY GREAT.